my talk today is
advertised is concerning what is taking
place in
Palestine as an
umah as a nation what can we
do it is now
Saturday November 4th and more than
9,000
Palestinians have been killed since the
7th of
October many of them were women and
children the scenes we are
witnessing are
heartbreaking and
traumatizing
distressing
to every
believer and any decent human
being this pains the
believer and this pain is a sign of
Iman the prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam he said in
theith narrated
by that comes in the inkari and
Muslim
the like of the Believers in their
affection love and mercy is like one
body if one part of the body feels
pain one of the part of the body feels
pain the rest of the body it reacts and
it
responds with sleeplessness and
fever
yes explained in thisi this is the
relationship of the Believers if the
Believers are sad n no doubt this will
affect other believers he
said
he said If you experience pain in one of
the extremities of your body say for
example your toe if you bang your toe
against the
bed then this pain would radiate in the
entire
body he
said this is how you should react and
behave towards the Muslims meaning if
they feel pain you feel
pain if they are saddened you are sad
sadden if they are hurt you are
hurt if one of the Muslims experienc
this
pain then it should be as if the matter
affects you
directly however how do we
respond what should be our understanding
look the Hadith is
clear
the like of the Believers in their
affection their love their mer Mercy is
like one body If part of the body feels
pain the rest of the body responds with
Sleepless sleeplessness and
fever it is upon us firstly brothers and
sisters we
pause and we have to view this in light
of what we find in the Quran and the
Sunnah we have to take our emotions away
from it it's difficult but it must be
done and it will become clear inshallah
T later on it is upon the Muslim to
understand that this is a test from
Allah and Allah's wisdom is
infinite we always maintain good
thoughts about
Allah we always maintain good thoughts
about Allah not like some people well
the atheists and the agnostics when they
say if there was a god this wouldn't
happen we have an answer for that inshal
we have a response the response is
easy not like some they say you know why
has God forsaken the Palestinian people
we have a response for
that that's evil thoughts about
Allah we always maintain good thoughts
about
Allah in good times and bad times and we
firmly believe as M
Moses he said in the face of
pharaoh who threatened and he actually
perpetrated the
ACT he killed the sons of the Believers
at that time and he kept their women
alive as Allah informs Us in the
Quran
said he said I'm going to slaughter
their
sons Mass genocide and he actually done
it I'll keep their
women and I we will totally subjugate
them
what did M say in response to
this that Tyrant tyranny will always
collapse ISL said do not worry
oppression it will bring down the
strongest
Tyrant because Allah hates
oppression I have forbid an oppression
for myself and I have made it forb
bidden amongst you Allah hates
oppression oppression will haunt the
individual in this world in the don't
think they can go to sleep they need all
types of
medications to
cleanse their mind and their soul they
will never be able why because if you
condone the killing of women and
children you will never be able to have
a good night's sleep don't worry it will
haunt him in the D and more so in the
but listen how mus responded this is how
we should respond this is the respond of
the believer that looks at the bigger
picture because sometimes we're overcome
by our emotions no there's a bigger
picture there's this world but this
world is not the end there a
Hereafter and we can't see what's going
to happen in 2 years or 3 years or 10
years no look what M he said to his
people when they were threatened with
this Mass
genocide
MOS said to his people advising them in
light of these
threats seek aid from Allah and be
patient this Earth it belongs to Allah
he gives it to whom he chooses from his
servants the ultimate success the
outcome the conclusive outcome is for
the pious in the long term it may not be
now May not be in a year but know for
certainty success is for the Believers
it's for py not for
oppression no brothers and sisters that
these trials and tests n from the wisdom
of these trials and these tests what
we're seeing in
Palestine they reveal many things they
show the true nature of people many
people they claim hypocritically to
worry about human rights but they say
that this is defense killing women and
children is defense don't talk to us
about human rights after
this because anyone who condones the
killing of women and children they
should be the last to talk about human
rights he
said he said a time of times of turmoil
at times of
turmoil FNA many people are exposed it
brings out the
reality of
individuals
said
he said these trials and Innovations
have exposed many of the people and
removed the veil which concealed the
evil principles yes it would expose the
fascists like those who say everyone in
Gaza is guilty because they elected
Hamas as we will get to that's the same
reasoning as
Isis two fanatical sides to a filthy
coin
it exposes the racists and the fascists
and the islamophobes but also the people
of innovation who go around making of
the calling the scholars the Y of the
and government agents it brings out the
reality of
people Allah informed us about this in
the Quran when he
said those who disbelieve they spend
their wealth to hinder people from the
path of Allah
and Allah subhana tal me mentions in the
next verse the reason behind trials and
tests why are people going to be Tri why
are they going to be
tested so that Allah can distinguish the
good from the wicked and he places the
evil ones on top of one another and the
Hereafter they're going to hell may
Allah protect us from
that this humanitarian catastrophe what
we are seeing in Gaza and it's not just
Gaza it's also the West
Bank it highlights the patience of The
Honorable Palestinian people may Allah
preserve
them when we look at these things also
we have to now no doubt it saddens us
but there are also things that
alhamdulillah motivate us because the
Muslim is always optimistic even in the
darkest of times it highlights the
patience of The Honorable Palestinian
people in the face of adversity and
persecution their courage and
determination to try and live a normal
life is a lesson for us all imagine
being in an open air prison for that
amount of time where your water is
controlled your food is controlled your
electricity is controled imagine living
like
that and they live like this and they
continue to try and live a normal
life and we remind them and we remind
ourselves the prophet sallallah alai was
he
said because we look at that and we
think that's awful but we don't
understand that this is good for the
believer they will be rewarded by the
will of Allah the prophet said in theith
narrated
by amazing is the affair of the
believer for the situation is nothing
but
good and this is only for the believer
look amazing is the affair of the
believer every situation they find
themselves in it is good for them Subhan
Allah how many of us think about that
when we see these clips and again don't
look at too many of these
clips because they're
traumatizing they can lead to PTSD we
know what's going on we've seen
enough we've seen the clips we know
what's going on we see the
numbers Allah grant them ease and
protect them but also we look from the
angle that anything that happens to the
believer is good whether it's a blessing
or whether it's a trial look the prophet
explained he
said if Allah blesses the believer they
thank Allah they're
grateful this is good for them because
why they're grateful to Allah Allah will
give them more
blessings and if Afflicted with the
Calamity they're patient and it's still
good for them
yes look for example the kufar they look
from a worldly point of view the atheist
they don't believe in a Hereafter the
believer is certain that there is more
than this world the children of the
Muslims they're going to Paradise that's
with the consensus of the people of
knowledge the children of the Muslims
they're going into Paradise they're
going to Jenna Subhan Allah we don't
know where we're going
so we should worry about our own selves
yes no doubt as I said that's a lipus
test testing the morality of mankind
children because children are innocent
Muslim children and non-muslim children
that's why we condemn the killing of
children in Palestine and even in Israel
because we are just and Allah commands
us with Justice even against people who
are transgressing against us there's a
principle we obey Allah concerning you
even if you disobey Allah concerning us
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
prohibited the killing of women and
children even at times of War that's
Islam
Justice that's why we can go to sleep at
night and even the children of the
non-muslims according to a number of
Scholars I believe it's the strongest
position they go to
Paradise by Allah anyone who condones
justifies or trivializes the killing of
children in any fashion is a wicked
terrorist whether an individual a group
or a
government and again this is our lives
you EXP exposes some
people and we reiterate the point that
we mentioned earlier those who say and
some politicians have said it in various
places that the Palestinians are guilty
because they elected Hamas this is the
same reasoning as Isis Isis say what
they claim that all Western civilians
are legitimate targets because they
elected their governments in their
lands again with regards to the in
innocent civilian
with regards to the innocent civilians
that are killed by missiles in
Gaza said in these circumstances they
are martys inshallah in the general
sense I'll read his words
yes again alhamdulillah we're positive
and still even in Dark Times we're
optimistic we never despair of the mercy
of
Allah we have to stay
balanced shei said when he was asked
about those who
die from missile attacks he
said if they were Muslims they're martys
in the general
sense he said if they are killed by
missiles then they're ruling in the
general sense yes there are some
differences as it relates to certain
rulings of jurist prudence in the
general sense they are
martys he
said and this applies to any Muslim who
is killed unjustly in any place and he
goes on will suffice with that as for
specific individuals brothers and
sisters then we must we must say
inshallah we can't say so and so is a
Shah unless there is a text in the Quran
and the Sunnah we say
inshallah we have to say it why because
if you say they're a mar and you don't
add inshallah you're saying they're
going to Paradise how do you know you
can't guarantee for them Paradise that's
against
the that's why a specific IND
they Shah inshah General said anyone who
dies from the Muslims in a missile
attack is a
Marty so when we see those images yes it
saddens us it pains us inshallah the sh
may Allah have mercy upon all of
them I want to
highlight how this catastrophe
highlights a number of things we've
mentioned some of them one it highlights
for us the importance of me and you
being better Muslims so that our prayers
can be accepted and our Dua
accepted if someone doesn't pray how are
they aiding the people if they make Dua
you don't pray you think your prayer is
going your your your pray or your Dua is
going to be answered and you don't
pray that is why going out to protest
and a person doesn't pray doesn't mean
anything doesn't mean anything a person
protesting and they're not praying Salah
is
worthless because who can change it look
M said to the people his people
what he
said seek the aid of Allah and be
patient why only Allah can change this
situation we are in and in order for
Allah to change our situation no doubt
we have to fulfill the commands of
Allah for the Muslims after the Shah the
prayer if the prophet Alat wasam said
about a person that his food was Haram
from forbidden means his drink was from
forbidden means his clothing was from
forbidden
means how is his Dua going to be
answered what about the one that doesn't
pray so for me and you yes we want to
Aid our brothers and
sisters turning to
Allah fulfilling the obligations
striving to stay away from the
prohibitions Nam so for us this lessons
what's the lesson
we become better Muslims that is why I
stated
on numerous occasions in this
predicament the mass should be
jam-packed the mass should be
jam-packed with the Muslims returning to
Allah
likewise it highlights the obligation of
repenting from our sins
Toba this is everyone because Allah said
in the Quran
what
evil appeared upon land and upon sea
because of what the people they earned
with their own hands so that Allah may
cause them to taste some of what they
earned so they may return back to what
is correct they may repent to Allah yes
that when when things Beall us we turn
to Allah we repent from our sins because
we see the danger of
sins
likewise brothers and sisters it
highlights the importance of a as only
Allah can Aid us and only Allah can
protect us look M said what seek the aid
of
Allah it highlights the importance of
only Allah can protect us we should
place our trust and our Reliance in him
alone and single him out with all
worship do you think the UN is going to
change anything Subhan Allah look they
couldn't even come together to vote for
a
ceasefire and you're going to place your
trust in them no place your trust and
your Reliance in Allah have upon Allah
that's the
problem too many of the people are
expecting the creation to do
something they couldn't even say about a
ceasefire for peace in this country
Subhan Allah an MP got fired from his
position because he called for a
ceasefire look how corrupt the system is
and yes Subhan Allah Muslims are still
being harassed do you think anything's
going to change Subhan Allah they fired
one of their own because he called for a
ceasefire he said Peace he never
supported any
extremism these people they change like
the
weather one minute look Subhan Allah as
we say we condemn the killing of
civilians anywhere alhamdulillah we
that's something historically it hasn't
changed from the beginning up until now
in public and private but these
individual one minute someone is this
one minute is some someone is that
Mandela according to them at one time
who was a non-muslim he was a terrorist
then you know he became the leader you
know they gave him the Noble Peace Prize
and other than that these people they're
like the weather they're dictated by
votes and money
corrupt the believer alhamdulillah is
anchored by the Quran and the Sunnah
likewise brothers and sisters what is
taking place it highlights the
importance of true Unity of the Muslims
true
Unity true Unity let's understand this
right yes the Muslims need to be United
but United upon the Quran and the Sunnah
with the understanding of the companions
not Unity with Iran or the proxy
militias some people I've seen on social
media when our brother shami may Allah
preserve him and protect him he put up a
post he said I'm coming to K somebody
said we prefer the Iranians over you
m
not Unity with Iran and their proxy
militias like the so-call hisbah or the
houis of Yemen the hthis of Yemen were
slaughtering aah a few years ago in
the they were slaughtering the people of
sunna and Yemen and you are turning to
them just because they let off a few
missiles to throw sand in your
eyes let's just show n of the so-called
that's all show to dup you into their
agenda because and Iran they want to
spread shiism in the Middle East and
they want to undermine every Sunni
regime look at Yemen after the so-called
Arab Spring Yemen Subhan Allah beautiful
country well I lived there Subhan Allah
for numerous years the people of
Yemen the prophet sallu alai wasallam
said a people that were poor but W the
hospital ality was
amazing when they the people thean and
other than them they went out and they
started demonstrating in the
streets against al
ABD opened the door for who open the
door for the houthis and the Iranians to
undermine the Muslims in Yemen and now
the huthis are running rampant may Allah
protect the people of
Yemen
Iran desires to
spread she
m in the Middle
East and one of the strategies that they
use is what to undermine the
Sunni governments and
states and they will use the poor
Palestinians as sacrificial Lambs to
achieve that they don't care about the
Palestinians it's just propaganda for
them but how many people can see past
the propaganda and understand the
reality even some of sadly some of many
of the sunnis are
fooled go back and read your history
that's the problem knowledge we need
knowledge not Tik tock not YouTube not a
tweet on Twitter or they call it X
now we need to know the Islamic history
we
need mentions the role of the in aiding
the tars to enter the Muslim lands the
ra the sh how they aided the Crusaders
and so on and so forth we can give a
lecture just on
that when you're saying that you know
yes we should work with the Iranians you
don't even know the goal of the Iranians
how do you think some of the people
accepted it was because of their
ignorance and emotions they rally you up
so you can't even tell what's right or
what's
wrong likewise brothers and sisters what
is taking place it highlights our need
for the major Scholars the scholars of
the um the like of
and the senior Scholars who are living
like and other than them and
others why because alhamdulillah they
can understand things how they are meant
to be understood the scholars speak with
wisdom these individuals this their
beard have gone gray teaching the um
about andah warning against
and they don't change their positions
based upon politics
this no doubt what we are seeing Subhan
Allah this barbaric Behavior the killing
of women and children they're saying
Subhan Allah I saw some commenters
saying it's acceptable for them to bomb
a refugee camp because they wanted to
Target one
individual sounds like Isis
right to bum a refugee camp women and
children to Target one
individual
subh how can that be
justified now be careful of demagogues
this is another thing that's important
for the shabab the youth beware
the we fear that you're going to have
the
same Trend occur that happened after
9/11 that you're going to have armchair
instigators radicalizing the youth
anyone who is sitting in the house in
America or in Europe and telling you to
go to Syria W be suspect them why
because we know that the are upon
falsehood but if they were truthful they
would be leading the way they wouldn't
be sitting in their house eating their
dinner now watching maybe watching the
television or the news and sending you
away to be killed for your destruction
or if you don't end up being killed you
end up in prison
well parents monitor your children
because these individuals are upon the
internet and I'll mention some of their
names one of them that is becoming like
the m a convey about to the to the
extreme groups he's from
theed anyone you see promoting him know
that
they're anyone ahed a man who's sitting
I think in Dearborne
Michigan on his sofa
encouraging your children to go and get
involved in stuff that will bring
nothing but destruction and regret in
this and detrimental and harmful if they
disobey the commands of
Allah
likewise as a Muslim we always remember
that Allah subhana wa ta'ala
he will bring the Tyrant and the
oppressor to account Allah said in the
Quran
don't ever think Allah subhana is
heedless about what the oppressors are
doing again look how we have good
thoughts about Allah Allah emphasized
this never think that the oppressors
that Allah is unaware of what the
oppressors are doing Allah knows exactly
what they're
doing and even though they may think
it's in their interest is going to haunt
them and I could go into various ways
even from a worldly point of view but
I'll leave that that's not the place or
the time right now they think this is in
their interest it's not in their
interests because for the Muslims this
is not the first test it's not going to
be the last test the prophet sallallahu
alai wasallam he
said when he was asked
by he
said who from the people are Tri the
most the prophet
responded he said the prophets and then
those who imitate them the most and then
those who imitate them the
most a man will be tested on the
strength according to the strength of
their
religion if somebody's religion is
strong then their test will be
strong if there is some weakness in
their
religion they will be be tested
according to their religion and a person
calamities will afflict the servant
until they walk the earth and they will
not have any sin upon them when you're
tested it's an experation for sins look
at the Muslim how they view
tests look at the beauty of
Islam this is why the companions Subhan
Allah during bad when they were faced by
an when they faced an enemy that was
three times their number but remember
they had the Muslim state in Medina and
the leader was the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam look at their courage
and their
forbearance why
because their belief was
firm also the prophets and The
Messengers they were tested the most
Allah he said in the Quran some of them
were
[Music]
killed Allah tells us here look he said
those who disbelieve in the the signs of
Allah they kill the prophets of Allah
some of the prophets were killed They
Carried the message of Allah also they
kill those from the people who stand up
for justice give them Glad Tidings of a
severe torment prophets were
killed so the question
arises how do we respond to this
persecution and injustice how do we
respond as
Muslims how do we respond as Muslims and
we're in the west we're living in
Western lands how do we respond
again look at the example of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam don't listen
to the
armchair instigators who are going to
Rally you
up play upon your emotions and have you
going like a yo-yo in whatever direction
that they want
no look at the Quran and the Sunnah how
do we find in the Quran the prophets and
The Messengers how did they respond to
persecution how did the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam respond to
persecution one example and this Hadith
declared it to be
sound we know y his father his mother
they didn't have any tribe when they
were in meccah to protect
them so obviously they were an easy
target and on one occasion the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam passed them
by and were torturing
them they were torturing the family
imagine you walk by and you see a whole
family being
tortured at that time the Muslims they
were weak in
mecah the prophet how did he respond
look Subhan Allah based upon in Allah
Revelation from Allah the prophet he
said he said to
them he said patience oh family of Y
your promise is Paradise s was later
stabbed in her abdomen and she was the
first martyr in Al Islam why because
it's based upon ability you respond
based upon your ability to respond in a
way that is
legislated notice how the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam advised them
to be patient when you have Scholars
today advising the Muslims to be patient
because of the weakness they'll say
you're a Zionist or you're a Jew or
you're a government
scholar why because again these
individuals they want to play upon your
emotions the prophet he said he
witnessed them being tortured by the
polytheists why were they being tortured
they were being tortured because they
said our Lord is Allah they worshiped
Allah alone because they were Muslims
the prophet said to
them at this stage be paent patient oh
family of Y and your promise promise is
Paradise again there
inkari said look at the
prophet we're living in non Muslim
countries and even those who are even in
other countries in some of the Muslim
countries
this is
in the prophet and his companions they
used to ignore the pagans and the people
of the book as Allah commanded
them and they were patient with the harm
meaning this is when we are weak and we
were derive this from the statements of
the somebody may say well that's how you
understand it no we will hear the
statements of the
scholars and Allah said in the
Quran
you will surely hear from those who have
have been given the book and those who
associate partners with Allah much
harm you will hear much much harm but
Allah commands with what
patience
patience you will hear from them the
people of the book and those who
associate partners with Allah much harm
look what it says mentions another
verse the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to act upon this until
Allah allowed him to fight meaning until
they had the state in Medina and Allah
gave them permission to
fight